[Music]
yeah what is good it is good to be back
on this Thursday or whenever the hell
you're listening to it left going BER at
the side I'd yield back as you see in
the description Julian Edelman Super
Bowl MVP will be joining me for about 26
minutes of the great New England
Patriots six times super I just
mentioned six times two world champion
Super Bowl he has a documentary coming
out on Showtime Friday night called 100%
about Julian Edelman we dive into that
and then after the interview I'm gonna
kind of explain a little bit of my take
on discussing his suspension with him
because I kind of want to just clarify
some things but we do need to get to my
pool dunk rankings I like that you're
like we have a very important interview
coming up but first pool done right
let's let's be the real here and then
also an update on the 33 days of eating
like a homie
first and foremost though I want to say
thank you to all of the people that were
on my personal Instagram at Adam Lefko
showing me a lot of love for my outfit
at the NBA Awards which make up by woody
on Instagram is the one that hooked it
up the jacket was unbelievable it's
pretty sick jacket it felt really good
it was one of those things to wear when
you walk into the NBA Awards you're like
here's Bill Russell oh man there's Yanis
had that scoop oh and they're all
looking at you and they're like nice
jacket it's a great [ __ ] feeling who
was the most famous person you peed next
to over the weekend ooh I didn't really
go to the bathroom about three days I
was like I was man it sucked because I
really wanted to see Samuel Jackson but
I feel like he came in the back and only
did his award and then left
like I saw Minaj was like right over
there but yeah the MBA Awards are weird
I've never been to like an award show
before I've never been in that energy
before where it's like you're watching a
television broadcast and now nobody
wants to be in their seats
anymore it's really weird I was thinking
about this because with like the Oscars
no matter how famous you are Tom Hanks
is still unbelievably humbled to receive
an Oscar right no matter how great Tom
Hanks is but like draymond Green you
give him like Defensive Player of the
Year or whatever some year he's still
like I'm still dreaming greenly I got my
accolades cuz I made my millions and I
want to just like I've already got my
thing so it's weird to be in a room
where it's like this is a really
important award show and all the NBA
guys are like I already made my money
like you know the other thing that I've
realized is when you wear a interesting
jacket and you're white everyone just
says craig sager like that's what
happens that you just walk by there like
wait on or sager and I was like man I
love craig sager like legend like
incredible human what he brought was
amazing and I just started be like
you're what yeah man totally you do wear
cool jackets but I've never thought that
they were sager like jackets that one
was kind of Sagres
yeah I was a little garish but I've
never felt like you were trying to do a
sager you're just you just like cool
kind of bright colors so what's really
funny is my fiance like does like some
modeling and stuff like that
I'm he'll bring what's know it's just
fast but what's really funny is we went
to the red carpet we want to get there
early because we wanted the
photographer's like still have energy
and all that stuff and she went out
there and the cameras were going apeshit
turn turn over here over here and we
were laughing like today I was like do
you think they that they thought you
were a WNBA player like like quick or
because she has like some star qualities
to her like I'm not gonna like she's the
[ __ ] but I went out there and they were
like oh he must be with her choo choo
and I was like yo can I get some more
photos please and she was laughing about
it it was so funny they're like oh and
here's the guy with her cuckoo and they
had those really loud camera shutter
noises and you can tell how many cameras
were being going off oh they couldn't
hear anything when she up and when I
went up there one of them was like Adam
I'll take one and I was like god but it
was it was a really fun experience it
was really cool man and then I walk in
into the DJ goes yo Adam love goes in
the building check out the podcast and I
was like holy [ __ ] the 33% is growing
let's [ __ ] go once you've infiltrated
the DJs
it's all over man all right 33 days of
eating like a homie I want to say that
we're down to two people and I don't
know who to give it to because each of
these people [ __ ] crushed first one
on titter Twitter man that was a
Freudian slip combination of tinder and
Twitter which was kissing ass guy hit me
up on tinder and said listen shine
underscore slime my man has been
constantly updating me throughout this
entire process in 33 days he lost 25
pounds - and I just want to say of all
the people and we've had dozens of
people sending me in photos this guy
looks like a dude that would really
enjoy training with travell gains yeah
we're talking about throwing on the
weights on the back doing the dips like
this guy's grinding and he's like
shooting his shot all the time like
travell gains I'm coming for you so um
he's one of the guys the other one on
Instagram his account name is levo le
Evie and I think it's the number zero
his messaging was he was up to 320
pounds we say we're doing the 33 days
and to being a homie literally his
wedding was 33 days later oh wow down to
295 Mazel Tov
so he lost like 25 pounds as well all
for his wedding I have these two guys
one of these is an absolute mauler the
other guy is like the story that hits
you in the heart strings to all the
other homies by the way I am super proud
of you guys I hope you're looking around
your life right now you're like him I
feel good I know a Lefko didn't say my
name but I feel really [ __ ] good
right he read your tweet yeah oh I read
all of them I have them all saved I
haven't been a doc and if I didn't
respond and tell you a way to kick ass I
apologize I'll get to it but those two
I'm gonna talk to travell I'm gonna see
kind of what we can make happen maybe
he'll take both I will talk to him we'll
figure it out I literally am figuring
this out on the fly but those to shine
underscore slime way to go leave Oh way
to [ __ ] go proud of you homies way to
eat like a homey and
all the other people that said thank you
for doing this and whenever ma'am thank
you for sending that to me because
you're part of the reason that I was
able to eat a little bit cleaner because
I'd be sitting there going man I would
love a calzone right now and then I'd
read a D and that's like down six pounds
of this like the last two weeks in life
I'm getting spinach and can I make a
shout-out to those guys out there that
didn't lose the weight but are
maintaining the weight yes grateful eyes
guys respect okay cuz like I didn't lose
weight in the month of June I was trying
to lose a pound or two I'm at the exact
same weight that I was on June 1st but
you know what that's hard to do
sometimes too cuz you didn't gain any I
didn't gain it no doubt I ate like an
[ __ ] this week he's after my wedding
on Saturday that are a date I was like
oh no now I'm gonna go but I'm gonna get
back on it shout-out to the maintainer
z' I agree
okay so you've looked over my pool
rankings yes apparently our pool
rankings are a little bit more
legitimate now to like a pool float
they're blowing up
I just came up with that on the spot
sorry about that so yeah there was an
article written on the 247 sports a some
that's 24/7 sports this guy is is
actually like quoting the criteria for
what goes into a pool producer David
ingmar even had four criteria I you know
I can't believe somebody wrote an
article about the pool rankings I just
couldn't believe I got name checked in
it because I have a Google Alert just
cuz I like to know if you really yeah
Google Alert for your own name just in
case there's some [ __ ] that you need to
combat and it just popped up it popped
up in my email box it was like oh
something about David I assumed it was
rabbi david Ingeborg who's a lot more
famous than I am but no it was a it's a
David Ingeborg that's something about
pool rankings and I was like oh and sure
enough this guy John Newby did thank you
John breakdown like this was like the
Zapruder film broke everything down
about the pool rankings and what we're
thinking about and why Derek Aussie
number one he included a great tweet of
Derek Carr like just jiaying up and his
dog's eye which was really funny and
hitting a yes and then David Carr
Derek's brother
retweeted our tweet and said these
rankings are right I saw Derek recently
jump out and do a between the legs like
these rankings are being done solely
because rankings are ridiculous and like
who cares where quarterbacks are right
into
their pool rankings it's just fun thing
to talk about right and it's starting to
become a thing thing and then it's
cracking me up the more people get mad
at you the boy you just want to make
more people like you
Mariota would suck at pool dunks it's
clear that Cam Newton would be a much
better dunker than Fitzpatrick and I'm
like I don't know smaller guys have an
advantage like that's actually a fair
criticism yeah once you come back at
them they're like oh actually he's
thought about this hmm all right so what
do you what do you have about my
rankings I just wanted to put a scenario
in front of you okay because if we're
gonna decide so no real so what we're
gonna decide who the best pool dunk
right pool dunker is we would need to
have a pool dunk contest which means we
would have to throw the best pool party
in the history of the world right with
all 32 starting cubies man I'm just
trying to come up with the scenario
ahead sure you know how it is at any
given pool party some of the older guys
don't necessarily want to get in the
pool some guys are like on the phone the
whole yeah so I actually started
factoring that in I started thinking
like Tom Brady might just be like you
know what I just don't feel that sold a
car the reason he was lower on my list
and don't Flacco's not getting amped to
jump in the pool Aaron Rodgers also
struck me as as the sort of guy that's
like you know what I got I have a lot of
phone calls to make I a very important
meeting because I had Aaron in the
middle mm-hmm yeah I'm just throwing
this out there's like the sorts of guys
look to things he your situational like
high like thing I thought Aaron was the
guy that you think isn't gonna do
anything hmm and out of nowhere takes
the shirt off and does an impressive one
and then gets out of the pool and puts
his shirt back on
so I hated one-timer I had Andrew Luck
as my guy that would do that really I
just feel like Andrew you know Andrew
looks like you know he's talking to his
Stanford buddies over by the guacamole
and they're like oh he's not getting
again the pool that's fine whatever and
then all of a sudden we're doing pool
dogs rips off the shirt does a 360
through the legs you know Vince Carter
mm yeah and then just pops right back up
he's like so anyway you were saying
about Keats no no no uh what was your
fault though with like this hypothetical
pool party though oh I just liked
thinking about it as another way of it's
another way into describing who would be
the best pool dunker as opposed to who
would be the best showman like again I
you know I stand for
Josh Allen yes just like a great show
yes great jumper loves to show off his
physical gifts feels like a guy that
would that would rise to the occasion
with a big crowd around the edge of the
pool July 4th is weird this year because
it's like a Thursday oh so it is it's
gonna be next week so I think I think
kind of heading into next week
I think the ranking I want to do is July
4th grilled masters that's great heading
into that week so I think next week's
ranking will be who is the best
quarterback to man the grill for your
July 4th party yeah because now the last
few ones have been a little athletic
this now actually favors the old guys
right I go on on Instagram or Twitter
and I see Drew Brees had like some pork
shoulder and was roasting it for about
eight eight hours I'm sorry no one under
the age of 27 can be considered a grill
master you just need reps you got to get
your 10,000 hours in I would say this
actually benefits the older guys right
Phillip Rivers likely up there oh yeah
because every time he makes burgers to
the family he make 25 burgers there is a
supply practice yes and his reps in
Brady I don't know though not the guy I
want man in the grill he's the guy you
want if you're having portobello
mushrooms he's doing you know a toe
furger know what I mean he might give
you the impossible burger though hey
which would be pretty cool of the
impossible burger I'm trying to think
who else that like Andrew Luck would be
the guy that actually has a meat
thermometer and it's like very
particular yeah it's actually a 40%
Chuck 40% like shoulder 20% pork blend I
read about this on Martha Stewart's blog
Carson Wentz is actually serving you
steaks that he hunted the animal earlier
that day so there is gonna be a little
freshness factor
yeah with him yeah mahomes I would say
it's gonna be a little bit KC barbecue
you know I mean like there's also a
regionality to this right where where
you're from you know Cam Newton he's
vegan and he's dealing with Carolina not
a huge fan of those dynamics but there's
that southern hospitality if you're
gonna factor in location right if you're
in Carolina they're gonna take care of
you at a barbecue but this is the thing
are we just doing the grill master
because like I don't want drew brees
bringing the coleslaw but he might be
Abel came flipping some hotdogs sure you
know yeah yeah okay there's a lot to
think about you you clearly put more
thought into this than I just thought
about it right now going through it as
we see on the fly you know just try
think of like older guys that would do
well Eli's interesting but he might
drool on your burgers because his mouths
gonna be a gape the entire time mm-hmm
all right a lot to consider a lot to
consider now it's an interview with
Julian Edelman as you're gonna see
Julian has been on a wild press tour the
last few days a car wash as he was on
Good Morning America he was on Stephen
Colbert what's interesting about these
guys are he is a Super Bowl MVP that has
a documentary coming out Friday and we
even said this at the end he's like man
like he said I appreciate what you were
doing he was because I keep getting
asked the same [ __ ] questions you
know what I mean of course and so I
appreciate him coming in here doing 26
minutes I asked him about you know what
was the did Belichick ever make you
laugh when did you know that Tom Brady
was crazy
you called him the greatest Jewish
athlete since Sandy Koufax we dig that
he dug that he was into it yeah he was
like I don't want to accept that and I
was like no just [ __ ] take it you
said that to me you know before he came
in and yeah wow that's a bold statement
then I started thinking about it like
yeah he's the Super Bowl MVP you top
that yeah so I hope you guys like it and
then afterwards I kind of want to talk
about the suspension so stick around but
in the meantime here is Super Bowl MVP
Julian
[Music]
I see a little finger tap I had it at
about nine to one that you might
freestyle I feel like you're a possible
freestyle guy hey hey hey no do it
julian edelman in the house Super Bowl
MVP appreciate you coming through
um I'm realizing you're May 22nd 1986
I'm May 8th 1986 I'm Jewish you're
Jewish
we both had growth spurts our junior
year of high school I feel a little bit
of kinship to you and I realized I did
some research I think I have found the
song that would have been your walk out
song about a decade ago
can I play it for you do you know nard
water at all that's yeah okay I think
this is it I feel like this was the one
for you especially this part yes because
I'm looking say your nickname used to be
juelz santana a lot of guys used to call
me Juelz nice in college college mostly
college JUCO a little bit so Juelz cuz
that's when he was I was popping you you
get there in 2006 that song drops 2005
I'm like that had to be his walk out
song you know it's so far back now
really that like dude you lift so many
lifetimes at this point
without an in in I don't you you have so
much going on in your life and you had
so many crazy memories yeah that you're
like someone brings something like that
up you're like holy yeah probably was my
stuff your documentary comes out Friday
night Showtime 100% by the way great job
to lock in that title also how was that
title not taken before you know yeah
right
I don't know we were thinking about
titles in like halfway through all the
shooting all I said was like a hundred
percent yeah hundred percent yeah and so
you know we kind of
fell into and then also the parallels of
always striving for that hundred percent
had always been at that hundred percent
it fit perfect we felt when you watch it
all back and I'm sure you've watched it
so many times so many times that when I
did a documentary when I lived in
Louisville and by the one thousand time
you don't even want to see it any and
you think it sucks right because you see
all the whole everything and you're like
oh I was at that shoot we could have
gotten that other angle we missed that
one moment that it out yeah you know
it's it's uh but I enjoyed it I really
did I did I did I enjoy it I enjoy it
but like you're never done until
literally Aires you're just you nervous
I mean I don't know I don't think you
should be nervous I thought it came out
really well yeah plus you won the
Superbowl so you gave yourself and you
won the MVP so it gave you self this
incredible ending to it it was a good
ending yeah there's definitely a good
ending uh you know and it's I'm I'm
proud of it but I mean of course it's
you know it's like our first big big
little dot coast-to-coast productions
first documentary to launch it and
partner with Showtime which is a little
partnership yeah you know it was it was
uh you wanted to do well you know yes I
playing a game I Burger Time was the
first time that I ever saw you do stuff
on camera with Chandler Jones and I
remember going oh this guy wants to be
an actor like I I could tell and then
the smoothie times and all the videos
are you really like sitting in a room
coming up with content ideas because I
imagine that most fans think you're and
they're studying the playbook but like I
know that you have this other passion
it's evident well you know there's
there's a lot of downtime in the off
season and you know you train from you
know 8 a.m. til one o'clock and you know
earlier in those years I didn't have a
kid and we were sit back you get bored
you you weren't really doing anything
else and you just come up with ideas
your passions and things that you were
interested in and tried to put a little
twist to them and my
you know my brainstorm partner saw he's
my partner in Khost productions you know
we got a cool relationship where I can
spit out an idea to him and he can make
it go or he could give me an idea and I
could tweak it or this that and anything
that kind of like makes me comfortable
he's good at adjusting on the fly with
that yeah so it's been fun and we
originally started doing it just because
you know in New England you know when
it's work it's work yeah when it comes
to work media it's work media this was
kind of a way for you to kind of get out
and show people you're a little bit of
your personality and and a way to kind
of communicate with fans I am I had
drinks with Amendola after the final
four cuz Texas Tech was down here and I
was like me you're a [ __ ] lunatic and
I'm and then I see when you guys went to
Mexico City and what you guys did and
and kind of the fun you brought to that
when you hear like the lame Johnson's go
they don't have fun in New England and
New England fans get very like defensive
they're like leave us the [ __ ] alone for
someone that has fun in New England
what's it like to hear that well I mean
it's it's there's working in there's
play I think that's in any profession
there's you know there's there's things
that aren't the funnest things that are
tedious that you have to constantly work
you have to constantly sharpen you know
we do have a high-stress environment
because we have a standard and and you
got bill he's a the thing is when you
see your leader act the way he wants you
to act or actually work his heart like
right this guy doesn't take a down play
your day to week off I mean it's it's
it's incredible vacations are just
working in a nicer climate you know
without a doubt has he ever made you
laugh off the top of my head no but I
know he has I mean he's made me laugh
he's got it he's got a dry sense of
humor and yeah you know he'll bust out
with some here and there that'll make
you giggle but like I really hear
balichek in person
everyone's been making me try to do this
I'm running out of lines I don't notice
it my thing is of all the guys in the
team if anyone's gonna have the
confidence to actually go to Belichick
and kind of to me it's you people would
sell Rock but I feel like you would kind
of go up there and be like hey man I
really dig the sweatshirt today bro well
I do I do do those kind of yes I would I
don't do the the impersonation and in
front of him if he came up to you this
offseason in training camp and said
Julian I hear you've been going around
doing the impersonation do it in front
the team would you be nervous to do it
in front of him like would it scare you
a little bit not not if I got his
blessing oh so if he told you it's okay
it's fine yeah he's like he's like dad
brother if he says it we're good that's
awesome
you know he's it's it's it's a crazy
relationship because as much as like
when you're when you're there for I've
been there for a while and for the first
part of my career we didn't we didn't
speak much but the times he did speak to
you it was like the heavens opened up
and like I don't know if he does it on
purpose which I'm convinced he probably
does it's all planned it you know he it
makes like he can not even really talk
to you and but he can talk about the
unit and then it'll make you work hard
and then the one time that he does say
something like that's like what make
sure makes your week what was do you
member the first one I think you know
there was like a play in like my rookie
minicamp or something or you know I got
off a release or I did something that
the coach asked us or he said in a prior
meeting like we need to do this like it
could have been a stick technique or a
whip technique and you nailed it and I
you know I I was I just tried to do what
he said and he you know he said this is
what we need to do you know this is how
good job you know and that was like and
it still is even to this day I mean
because no one's off limits I mean
he's still gonna if you don't do
something right he's gonna let you know
Foxborough high school can do this
better than you can yeah
I mean we've we've heard it and you know
I think that's what makes him a great
leader is that he makes everyone and he
puts everyone makes them all accountable
I'm watching the doc and I see you lead
the team out for the Super Bowl is that
something that just happened
did you get appointed that was a
conversation we all run out together I I
know I know y'all together but here I am
watching this guy that's fought back
from the ACL the four-game suspension
and you're the one leading out with all
of your [ __ ] energy and the stadium
goin nuts and the flags like to your
left and right like did I know you guys
all run together yeah yeah but you were
in the front I've been doing you know
I've got a thing where you know I always
let Brady go okay and you give him like
Lou you know 10 20 30 yards because he
just trots yeah he trots out Teddy trot
steady trot and I liked it I like to
gear it up I mean I remember when I was
a kid I saw Jerry Rice and when he came
out of the stadium he would come out
give the low high fives and he would go
back and forth and get the crowd
involved tonight so I don't know I kind
of not too original but I'd run down and
sprint and get to the crowd and give an
arm pump and I'll let's go and a couple
f-bombs here and there and yeah you know
it's just kind of something that gets me
going gets me mentally right and you
know I've been doing it for a while now
it's funny from the doc I saw you more
of a Deon guy than the Jerry guy because
you're right you're rocking the 21 with
the 49ers Jersey I'm like if you had a
bandanna under the helmet I wouldn't be
surprised I don't think you were allowed
to have him oh sorry yeah yeah could
have got in trouble I was gonna allow it
anyway he was actually cool with that
kind of stuff when it came to like you
know I always wanted to be swagged out
with the red Nike cleats to wristbands
21 I mean I think you know prime in
those days and even now he was just such
a trendsetter he was like he's like he
was the Odell Beckham of this this time
and age you know what I mean it just
loved him and he was a you know just a
swag fool
against the grain here and there but
ultimately he was the best at what he
did you know I mean and and I loved him
and he played he only played the Niners
for like one year it was a hell of a
years a hell of a year yeah yeah
Tom Brady your guys relationship is
pretty cool to watch because you know we
see him chugging the beer now and and
every story about Tom it's it's like
he's got to be perfect he's got to do it
right and when you get into that trust
tree it's got to be like such a great
feeling because I don't feel like it
opens up to a lot of people now you guys
are at this moment we're like you're
gonna be like lifetime best friends and
all that stuff what did you what did you
not know about him that you only learned
what you got into that trust tree you
know you always speculate how hard he
worked and obviously and and all those
things but the constant attention to
trying to improve even if it's bringing
in you know like a quarterback coach in
week 16 mmm just to work a couple
fundamentals just to feel confident like
all those feeling right things and and
not being too big sure the quarterback
coach or not being too big to to ask an
opinion from this you know what I mean
yeah just using his ability to work with
people and and to constantly sharpen his
his sword is ridiculous and you know
that's something you speculate but when
you see it it's uh it's something you
learn from and it's something that
trickles down because you know he's been
doing it for so long and he's been doing
it for so long at the highest level that
uh you know if you want to do some how
high level you might as well be in his
back pocket and look what do you know
what I mean - yeah his humility is
what's crazy his willingness to get [ __ ]
on by Belichick and still go out there
every day and keep going and and another
thing is is how nice of a guy like he's
a sweet person hmm it's funny like
I'll bust his balls and and and and get
on home and he's just you know try to
give it back he'll get me back but you
know he's just a loving dude yeah when
you see him with his family and his mom
and dad his kids his wife you know he's
just he's a real good he's a good good
he's good dude you Welker Randy Moss
Gronk do you think that you're his
favorite
I he's always done a great job too damn
to make everyone feel pretty important
yeah but like come on in your heart I
think you're his favorite now you know
you know cuz I was there when I wasn't
with Welker - yeah I was I was there
with it when Wes was Wes E and yeah I
had a little connection and you know I
was the rookie ER in the back frickin
hatin it with that long ass hair brown
hair and you know in with Randy I mean
he had a special relationship with all
those guys Deon love Deon I'm not sure
you know what I mean and and I think
that's part of his leadership skills and
how he is as a leader you know yeah he
makes makes you want to work hard for
him who who do you think retires first
you were Brady I hope I don't I hope I
don't but with him you don't know man
honestly hey I'm just worried about this
year and you know getting getting ready
and getting amped up for you know
training camp and getting back into the
swing of things you know sometimes it's
it's the best when it's football season
because then you can say no to things
and you know baby you know I mean you
you're balancing outside life with you
know training and doing all these things
you know it's it's it's it's nice when
it's that time I've always said on this
show that the most famous players in the
league the Odell's the Brady's that JJ
Watts the ones that when they don't have
a helmet on everybody knows where they
are and I feel like a lot of people have
been applauding juju as this young guy
that's adopting to social media he's got
his own YouTube channel and all that I
mean you were doing this [ __ ] like ten
years ago
Burger times smoothie time like these
random ass YouTube videos and all that
and I always hear from NFL athletes
about how hard it is to adjust when it's
over because that's your identity for so
long but I feel like you've been able to
maintain that other identity and I'm
just curious like how in a place where
it's focus on one singular task has it
been a release for you to kind of have
this other thing that maintaining who
Julian Edelman is I guess yeah I guess
it is it's a way for you to kind of get
away but also focus on something because
you know naturally you want to be
engaged yeah at least I do I like to be
engaged and I like to compete and I like
to work on something and and and and
have a goal and then you know try to
attain that goal and yeah go through the
you know editing this that you know all
with that so I think I could agree with
that it's it's an it's an outlet to kind
of go out and everyone's got something
they would like do enough off the field
and and this is developed into you know
becoming a passion so because you are
Jewish I believe it is fair to say that
you are the best Jewish athlete that
we've seen since Sandy Koufax think
about that you're a Super Bowl MVP he's
a SIA
and stuff yeah that's we don't see a lot
of Jewish athletes doing what you're
doing man hey yeah anytime you're in the
same sentence with the guy like Koufax
isn't that kind of crazy dick Ulis it
really is you know and and we could talk
more about that when I'm out because you
know yeah you know you know it feels
weird to even talk about place and time
and and future of this sure especially
with the way like you know I've been
wired with playing in New England with
my father is but like dude I'm watching
you online go on birthright like I went
on birthright and like I'm seeing you
like walking through them like the
marketplace and doing like like on top
of the mountain and all that [ __ ] and I
read this book last year called tough
Jews which was about how people don't
realize that New York gangs were started
by Jews
and they passed it on to Italians and
the last chapter is from the author
going I never grew up thinking about
Jews like that
all I ever groped was thinking about
they were kind of like a weaker people
that were always taking advantage of
throughout history and to actually learn
that they were the mobsters in New York
they were the first like Arnold
Rothstein and all this [ __ ] it actually
kind of lightened the burden for me
because it was like I knew that I was a
badass [ __ ] I just thought I was
the outlier and I wonder with you how
many young Jewish kids are actually like
I can play football like I really think
about that sometime yeah do you ever
think about that uh no not really you
know not as much yeah you know you go
out there and you hear these kind of
questions and you almost have it's
almost you know it's part of your life
now but yeah when you're in it it's it's
different man you got that singular
focus like it's hardcore and it's been
getting out of control just with like
this whole tour of where you hear all
this stuff yeah I mean like you know
there's that you know when you have when
you have a goal and when you have a
process of what you want to do you know
selfishly you you try to only focus on
that now you want to open up and I do a
lot of things that you know help other
people and/or help my people and and try
to inspire like you man I'm Jewish
you know and I mean so like I'm not
something that like goes to like Shabbat
dinners and all that but I grew up in a
reform you know synagogue but it's like
just representation for anybody is so
big yeah without a doubt and I just got
back from Israel two days ago
I used the Robert Kraft trip I met him
out there and went and supported mr.
Kraft we're getting the genesis prize
which was amazing it was awesome
and then I just chilled out and in Tel
Aviv and go Tel Aviv is an underrated
party city in this world that nobody
knows about it's an awesome city it's a
great city
great food great people yeah you were
talking about the exhausting part of
this like process yeah and I know it has
to be dealing with the suspension and I
think you what you showed in your
documentary not talking your dad for 81
days I have members of my family that
don't talk to each other and it's
because of something that happened and
it's emotional he comes back he helps
train you during those four weeks what's
interesting is I watch your documentary
I really enjoyed it
so much of your Jacque documentary is
you haven't it take the long way right
yeah you have to go to Juju's hey there
you go all comes back but you have to go
to JUCO you have to go in as a
quarterback to convince people that
you're a wide receiver it's always the
long way and in the part where you're
talking about your suspension
you're almost dealing with people saying
that you've taken a shortcut it's like
the first time in your life where people
are seeking of a shortcut yeah what was
that like to personally deal with just
you've always gone a long way and now
they're saying shortcut well I mean it's
it's I've been dealing with someone
saying something my whole life so I've
had to go back in and how did I get from
here to here well you know I just
worried about things that I could
control did something happen
something happened what happened oh
there's an obstacle what are you doing
well you're trying to get to here so at
this day let's focus on everything
that's gonna help me get here even if
something you know what I mean
it's just moving forward it's it's it's
trying to have that that laser focus on
what you're trying to do and you know
things happen that's life and and and
that's what that's what's cool about
this documentary it's it's not just a
sports doc it's it's a it's like a life
story of how you know someone in a
workforce that just so happens to be
football deals with his family not being
where he wants to be going through a
piece of adversity having to you know
another piece of adversity hit him up
and then all of a sudden trying to
manage all those things and ultimately
get back to where he wanted to be and
you know we lucked into a lot of this
you know this whole story fine
and it's been crazy but uh you know
that's life and life's like that and
I've been telling people you know after
you know in 2012 I'm on my first
contract I have I'm having a good year
I'm starting to get a lot of clock a lot
of burn had a great offseason you know
I'm getting some time all of a sudden
boom break a hand alright out three
games you know heal up come back all of
a sudden you know I come back falling
out for three weeks you have a bunch of
touchdowns teams doing well I'm involved
I'm contributing boom break a foot into
my contract year you know something
happened I look back on that year I when
that year was done I was like man this
this hardest year of my life I mean just
the time he didn't work out this didn't
work out that didn't work out so well
that what did I do
I got back on the horse you worried
about what you could control you worried
about things that didn't waste your time
or burn your energy for the bad but the
things that could help you get to where
you want to go and then you know I
played out a year on a one-year deal had
a good year with team didn't do as good
as we wanted to but you know ended up
getting another contract you know what I
mean and then and it all worked itself
out you know when it when I when I've
kind of you know brought my my helmet
and a lunch pail to work and worried
about you know the goals I've had for
that day or what I wanted to do that day
to improve myself even only 1% better
than I was the day before it's always
led me into the you know the areas that
I've wanted to go yeah I think I want to
end on this one my my audience we caught
they call themselves the 33 percent and
the way we've cut them and going this
offseason is that some people say some
[ __ ] that has been like things they can
take with them like tools and you're a
kind of person that can get up at five
o'clock in the morning can push
themselves to where really [ __ ] hurts
and wants to do it again the next day
and I think that a lot of people want to
do that to themselves and they they see
it and they want to do it but for some
reason they [ __ ] can't or they stay
in bed too long or they
it's news on the alarm and I'm curious
like what is one thing that you could
pass along to them that when you wake up
in the morning is you're not worried
about [ __ ] snooze you're getting
right out and you're doing like what is
something that they could take a tool to
help with that yeah my dad always told
me you know he goes you know life is
hard but it's simple you know what you
have to do you know you have to
condition today you know you have to
work out now do you always do it
no that's hard but it's still simple if
you know what you have to do you're
gonna and you go out and do it and you
improve your gonna see progression no
doubt you know that's one of the things
you know and it's also working smart and
knowing what you're working hard for a
lot of people can just go out and work
hard and not know what they're working
hard for you know that's why you gotta
use you know people in your life or
coach or you know someone who's a mentor
or business partner or this that you got
to find out what you need to work hard
at and if you work hard at that yeah I
mean you're naturally gonna improve in
some sort of way no doubt yeah all right
play that music and we'll see if
Julian's gonna freeze that Julian
element Super Bowl MVP back again hey
hey Peter the one could do it again we
got Julian Edelman is now all frank cuz
he can catch the ball from baby across
the middle we got Gronk
stop it hey little bit Oh hit it in the
flat take it out back he could throw the
ball and blow watch it back in a corner
back thank you again to mr. Edelman for
coming on and sharing some time as I was
saying before the man is on a press
circuit right now promoting his
documentary hundred-percent that comes
out Friday and I could tell after a
while that it can it can get to him it
gets exhausting you know what I mean but
the one thing that I wanted to address
is I'm seeing us in other media outlets
this notion that it is my respond
bility to be the Barbara Walters and
really press Edelman on the suspension
and what happened with the
performance-enhancing drugs and and what
he took and I've thought about it a lot
and what I've realized is that's not who
the [ __ ] I am
and I'm not even making an excuse I'm
just telling you a fact I am not someone
that is gonna judge people I call this
the players podcast because I want to
get to know who these guys are as people
and I want you guys to get to know them
too and I'm a liquor drinkin weed
smoking a lot of my friends are
degenerates and for me to kind of hold
myself to this standard as though I am
the judge and the jury and that I can
look across at another guy and and I
believe that I have the right to look at
him and go explain yourself to me show
contrition to me I think is a pretty
absurd notion because I don't see myself
as that kind of a guy and I I find it
really interesting when people get up
there and they they act like holier than
thou and and that they deserve the right
to know okay I don't feel that way I
also think with with Edelman and his
situation all of his issues are
self-inflicted so the only person that
he's really hurting is himself in in
five years when his career is over and
five years after his career is over
he'll have to deal with this stuff when
he's up for the Hall of Fame for the
rest of his life he's going to have
people that are gonna come up to him and
that are gonna ask him that question
when he goes to a rival stadium people
are gonna yell [ __ ] at him so for me to
think that if I don't ask him I'm
letting him skate by he's never gonna
have to deal with it I just think that
there are some media members right now
that if you have a news show if you are
and outside the lines or you're doing
something that you believe it's
important to do the journalistic nature
of covering the sport then that's your
platform but in my mind
I don't believe that I live my life
where I'm in a position to question
somebody like that all I know is he's
gotten the suspension he is gonna have
to deal with this for the rest of his
life pretty much and I can't want to get
to know who he was to people and if if
you think that that's a cop-out then I'm
happy to have you on my show to where we
can talk about that and you can explain
to me how I'm supposed to run my ship
but until then I'm gonna refrain from
cursing but that's not how it goes
around here so I appreciate you guys I
appreciate the homies again shout out to
the two homies that kicked in the 33
days of eating like a homie out of the
park
shine underscore slime and leave oh
we're gonna see if we can talk to travel
gains and make this whole thing possible
next week a lot of good podcasts coming
but I wanted to kind of explain that
stuff for you because listen man I'm on
that plane I'm going how do I want to
talk about this with Edelman what do I
want to talk about and really like I'm
just a guy I'm not I'm not the arbiter
of truth I'm not the judge in the jury
and I'm sure as hell not Barbara Walters
so I appreciate you guys Nick if you
want to play a little bit of music right
now so I can go off and stop my rent I'd
appreciate it but shout out to you guys
hit me up on social whether it's at left
coast show or at Adam left Co and also
do me a favor go onto Twitter go on
Instagram hit up Edelman say man we
appreciate you coming on I talk to him
at the end about maybe doing something
bigger next offseason maybe taking a
trip let's see if we can make that
happen
but always want to give you guys the
honesty cuz I'm never gonna front I
don't got time for that [ __ ]
love y'all very much on the lef koe man
and I will holla holla holla at you guys
later
[Music]